welcome to this video playing that porn
85 let's see from Australia if you need
to look up the New Zealand flag this a
bit it's not so far from that ok we have
a bank oh and I accepted it slide
transposition the fianchetto variation
and that is this notorious book be one
line but i'm not sure i need to play
look be one here isn't this it is it is
quite similar but not coo not quite the
same ok probably i need to need the
smooth anyway i'm not an expert be 33
maybe you can place you fall ok 10 so
that i have it before if necessary yeah
this is sometimes a possibility but i
thought i have just this move right we
should be 595 a text to queen
okay so if i go a form c4 that's not d
for this looks like a disaster yeah well
then this is a good news rice plane very
very quickly and in this is in this very
critical position already this already
looks like blackest on the edge here and
to be honest it's a yeah okay he's just
dashing out some move hoping to know
what it's really not a standard position
I mean we should play instantly it's
it's already very very critical I have
accomplished something already here with
8 a-4 be three on c4 FB form and to ask
very exactly ass Plex play it's not
clear the question is how to how to
continue many many possibilities I can
even try to exchange this Bishop with 91
bishops III come on let's do that the
only meaningful play here c4 and I have
before against that
yeah we can you can do that you can get
the night over to before but this is
purely on a purely defensive measure
it's not it's not doing anything active
check
so what's the plan yeah maybe I should
should even play 95 and tending 96 so
that I can play a phone yeah I'll do
that and better quickly I'm a bit down
on time of quite sure where I spent the
time
just this and now I for you yeah
breaking breaking this open I mean the
trip Lee to a really bad structure for
black
every five next and then Knight f3 it
should almost win the five-pound
it probably needs to do something crazy
here don't know c4 or something like
that I don't think it's working but
maybe I just 95 on 95 you know nitey to
is not really doing much I can go to a
one
yeah just see if night 0 a bishop f1
yeah just push up that one to get the
route to the fr
Jim and not much the black and do early
look up seven that's some powerful way
to play this night the night 26 this
would be nice yeah but then don't see
how I mean the good thing is it's not
just in the tech it's also two extra
points so you don't need to do anything
fancy here really maybe Queen d2 526 m
get the deep on rolling yeah better get
a 7-under tech I could have played
Knight b6 also yeah would have been
better than allow this move but it's
it's not doing much right you know he
now needs to retreat and now Knight b6
or not yeah just win the edge rook
check yo and made on g7 checkmate yeah
he really played the opening far too
quickly because this is I mean okay I
know if he does not know the the kind of
setup then it's it's probably a lost
cause anyway this is the most dangerous
set up against the bank oh and the
general set up with the fianchetto and
black needs to be extremely precise to
not to not get get wiped off the board
quickly anyway and I cannot really tell
how I display but I know that around
here I mean Bishop c4 is just giving
away two moves I want to play this
anyway and around here I think black is
already in big trouble he's the port
down and he has no compensation really
you can never go see for because of Abby
form reply in this case here after c4i
f94 even this is even more disastrous
and yeah I played all this instantly and
i think it's it's really a really
problematic already oh he was a mistake
oops he has Bishop d3 yeah but he played
this instantly again I overlooked the
smooth I mean I didn't really i thought
okay i go here but then i can take a
form mmm nice yeah i was playing playing
too quickly as well because i was just
thinking okay this guy's just plague
instant moves all the time and it's just
losing this in completely standard
fashion I don't need to play for it's
not the necessary mover can play Quincy
to first and then if all this is what i
should do probably and its really
questionable if black has any sort of
compensation in this position i think is
this is a kind of setup that you already
needs needed to prevent
before it's um it's a very critical line
against the bank oh ok thanks for
watching